oh man I love you so much I love you I'm
sorry to start in an awkward and weird
way but you know from from afar you know
we've never met we just met back
straight briefly but I've been too
frightened rabbits shows I've loved your
albums for a very long time where he
been hiding one time we were in the same
room eh okay but I was I was starstruck
I didn't want to bother ya see well I'm
a very you know I'm a silly guy and you
right kind of you know you can write a
good sad song are you a silly guy in
real life for you yeah well I mean I
think the thing that surprises people is
is just that you know I write about you
know emotional turmoil and then when I
mean you can't be like that all your
life or you wouldn't have any friends so
like I'm from Scotland so I don't like
writing anything particularly positive
but it's that yeah what's going on with
I've been to Scotland well wonderful
people but they're you guys enjoy it
pessimism is like a national pastime
yeah Frightened Rabbit what does that
mean where does the name come from well
I was very shy as a child my mom and dad
gave me that nickname because whenever I
was taken to social occasions I would
cower in the corner like a Frightened
Rabbit and no I wasn't really keen on
socializing so oh and then you know
conversely I know put all of my life
experience and everything that happens
to me into songs to be broadcast to the
world yeah yeah which is really smart
well I can be a little bit introverted
off stage as well I wouldn't say shine
necessarily but I will leave parties
quickly mmm because it's not for me
right and maybe that's why I relate to
meet your music so much you know well
yeah I mean it's it's like sometimes the
corner is the best place to be and I I
don't know like it's like a wall hug
there I guess it's you you actually face
into the corner oh yeah there's one
at home that looks like Daria like haha
finally a jug for me and your brother is
in the band is that right he is yeah
yeah occasionally you know I've hated
him since he was born so uh when he was
born I went to office Lee got taken to
see my new brother in the hospital and I
asked who his mum was what why I didn't
that make sense to me I was like where
where why do you have this other lady's
baby cuz how could she die thrown you as
right I was the special one I was the
young you know yeah still am oh you know
on the show and in my podcast I over
share a lot so then you get that sort of
parasocial relationship with your fan
base they do a lot about you I know
about your heart being broken and things
you've done since then and all a source
of it do you feel weird about that I've
kind of welcomed it though I mean I I
put the stuff out there and I'm sure you
yeah have it yourself you know when you
when you talk about your own life you're
welcoming people and often times when I
meet you know fans after shows they
already feel like they know me right
well they're quite happy to just cut
straight into the deep stuff right now
yeah I have people because I'm divorced
that'll come up to me and be like oh I'm
just like you I I couldn't get an
erection for mum yeah yeah I'm like well
I
that was their hand let me help anything
it gets better I think we have time for
one fishel question and this is a good
one for you talking about breakups
what's your ratio being dumped to
dumping and that's not just you that I
find that to be an interesting question
I don't think you should ask me why cuz
I'm not sure exactly how it happened I
see you picturing people's faces yeah I
know moments and then and then watching
this yeah we're like four yeah so I have
no idea about this flight or
invisibility as a yeah as a way of
breaking up with someone